and we're going to see connections that
that that of language models that maybe
you did not quite expect to anticipate
but they are very real and to start with
we are very lucky to have Stephen Panter
dossi uh he is a professor of Psychology
and Neuroscience at UC Berkeley and uh
uh a friend of of AI we actually have a
grant together and uh and and and and
you know how a lot of us in AI are
excited and interested in you know
learning from the psychologists and
seeing kind of how they can Inspire our
work well actually this is a two-way
street and because the psychologists are
also getting excited about the language
models to understand something about
humans and and Stephen uh will tell us
about about some of the work he has been
doing which is I think is very exciting
so Stephen
um so thank you for the invitation to to
speak here I'm going to be talking about
the meaning in the age of large language
models or maybe finding meaning in the
age of large language models and this
talk isn't a uh kind of technical talk
about language models or evaluation or
anything
um it's almost uh closer to philosophy
uh or closer to kind of high level
theories in in cognitive science and
psychology uh which are about meaning
um and some of the kind of history of
work of of people's ideas about uh where
meaning comes from in in language or in
in semantics and how we can think about
those in the context of large language
models in particular in the context of
debates about large language models and
uh whether they're just stochastic
parrots right that don't have any form
of understanding uh or whether there's
some sense in which they have
understanding and if they do have some
form of understanding uh if that form of
understanding is is at all related to
the types of understanding that uh that
that people have so my plan for for the
talk is first to talk about meaning and
reference kind of generally I'll talk
about some claims in large language
models and why people often think that
there's no sense of of meaning or kind
of real semantics in them then I'll talk
about some uh psychological theories uh
about meaning and how meaning arises
from what are called conceptual roles
I'll come back to large language models
and talk a little bit about learning
conceptual roles in large language
models or in in kind of General machine
learning systems and then some of a very
kind of brief overview of a learning
conceptual role experiment in people so
let me let me start uh with kind of how
I got interested in in this which was
this paper by bender and Kohler in in
2020 right so Emily Bender is a computer
scientist trained as a as a linguist
also at the University of Washington uh
who people may know as a very vocal
critic of of many aspects of large
language models the one that that
initially I think interested me was uh
claims about the meaningfulness of large
language models and essentially
arguments that uh there's nothing
meaningful at all in in what uh
statistical models that are trained on
text can can do
um and uh bender and Kohler came up with
a very nice way of uh of making this
point what they call the the octopus
test the octopus test goes as follows so
uh kind of starting point is for them
meaning is is an association between a
word say and something external to
language okay so the meaning of the of
book is some physical object a book
that's that's out in the world uh you
can see that that's right because that's
how we label physical objects and when
we're learning words right we hear the
word book when there's books around and
we pick up on that Association and so
that's kind of fundamentally what the uh
that kind of external reference right to
Something in the in the real world is is
fundamentally what uh what the word word
means
and Bender and callers say okay let's
take that as our our definition of of
meaning and let's imagine an octopus so
an octopus who lives uh under the ocean
and has tapped into a communication
Channel say a telephone line uh between
two islands okay see octopus is there
it's eavesdropping on all of the
communication that happens between those
two islands can get a huge amount of of
linguistic input
um and you could imagine very smart
octopus uh might be able to learn all of
the statistical properties of what's
Happening across that Communication
channel right might be able to learn uh
become very good at predicting text
maybe it could predict it optimally uh
whatever
um their argument is is that uh the
octopus could never actually learn the
meanings right because it would never
have access to the physical reference
right so yeah
yeah so it's it's uh interestingly a
little different from the Chinese room
um uh and maybe can I defer that
question to the end if that's okay uh uh
because I think what's going on with the
Chinese room might make more sense with
with what I say what I say later okay
but very very similar in spirit I would
say
um so this octopus has has uh has no
access to the physical reference and
therefore couldn't solve tasks involving
the physical objects right if you ask
them to visually recognize what a
coconut was even if they knew all of the
statistical properties of where the word
coconut would be used right they they
wouldn't uh wouldn't be able to solve
the the physical stuff okay and of
course this is the situation that a
large language model is in at least one
that's only trained on on text right it
doesn't get access to stuff from the
world it only has uh uh um kind of text
okay
uh therefore this octopus doesn't have
uh meanings for the words
um such an octopus is like a large
language model because they only have
text and predictive ability therefore
can't give you the meanings right
meaning is something just fundamentally
different than uh than predictive
ability
let me give you one other example of
this well I'll just say like I I think
that on the surface this is uh a
somewhat convincing argument right it's
kind of kind of compelling to to to
think of uh think of meaning in in this
way and certainly if you do it seems
seems pretty convincing yeah
in your mind
yeah great so uh hold on to that thought
too because a mathematician thinking
about axioms is a uh very much related
to another version of meaning that that
I'll I'll talk about in a few minutes
even as Hilbert wanted it to be right I
mean Hilbert's desire was to convert
euclidean geometry to a set of axioms
such that every symbol could be replaced
by some Arbitrage quicker and the system
should still work like that is what
Hilbert did in the axiomatization of
geometry
yeah so uh uh I I I I think most
mathematicians would have a slightly
different sense of meaning
um but but one which which matches what
I'll say in a few minutes so uh yeah
um let me give you just another uh
another kind of gloss on on meaning in
language models here's Gary Marcus
talking about Lambda uh in truth
literally everything the system says is
the sooner we realize that
lambda's utterances are just
games with predictive word tools and no
real meaning the better off will be
software like Lambda doesn't even try to
connect to the World At Large right
that's what he thinks makes it
uh just tries to be the best version of
autocomplete that it can be they don't
understand language in the sense of
relating sentences to the world uh uh
but just sequences of words to one
another
okay
so uh I got interested in in this uh in
part because I find that this View kind
of compelling uh on the other hand I
also think it's it's kind of deeply
wrong and the the way in which it's
deeply wrong is uh really interesting
for what it has to say about conceptual
representations and uh meanings in in
human Minds as as well as in machine
learning models
um so uh um in uh a few few years ago I
teamed up with uh Felix Hill who's a a
researcher at deepmind
um and wrote a uh and an article
basically uh going through arguments
that meaning is not this form of
reference right so in fact this idea
that meaning should be equated with some
mapping to things in the world uh has
often been rejected by people in
linguistics and and philosophy and and
cognitive science
um and I think for for a good reason
um so just to give you a kind of flavor
of
um uh why why people often reject this
there's many Concepts many words for
example that have no rep reference to
the external world right function words
are a good example of this where it's
like to or is or many right there's no 2
t o out in the world that that that word
refers to
um there's also no is out in the world
or or know many
um those are function words in in
language and uh what they do is actually
much more like uh kind of what you know
an operator in in mathematics or
something does right these words have a
an internal meaning
um they control the the kind of
compositional meaning of a sentence
meaning that they have to be composed uh
internally in linguistic representations
in order to express their meaning right
they're not pointing to something out in
the world
um even if you don't go to function
words like this there's there's other
words which are uh very hard to make
sense of in a in a kind of view that
meaning is stuff in the world so you can
think of very abstract words like
justice right there's probably not a
Justice out there that's some kind of
construct that we have or wit uh or you
can think of things that don't exist
like dragons right that's there's no
external external thing in the world
which is a dragon
um there's even words and and Concepts
we have that have no possible reference
to the world right so if I think about
an imaginary bicycle that's something
which is by definition imaginary right
it's not it's not out there uh or a
perpetual motion machine right we can
have a concept of a perpetual motion
machine and think about it and and
reason about it but there's certainly
not one that exists out in the world
um even for ordinary Concepts uh we
likely haven't even considered all of
the possible things which could be
reference of those Concepts right so uh
I could you know walk in wearing a shoe
made out of eggplants and you could look
at them and everybody might agree that
their shoes right uh but you would agree
that their shoes without ever having
seen shoes made of eggplants before
right so there's some object in the
world which everybody would agree is a
shoe uh even though you've never
encountered that thing before that means
that it couldn't have been the stuff in
the world which determined whether it
was a shoe right had to be some kind of
more abstract conception of uh what
makes something a shoe right you can
think about things like the function or
the origin how they're used uh these
these other kinds of properties of
objects seem to be much more important
for the the categorization of the
concept yeah
because you know eggplant shoes might
still considerably be considered shoes
but then you know Ice Cream shoes are
probably nobody will recognize them as
shoes right yeah but then you don't
think about ice cream so it's like the
things that you can think of as shoes
yeah are you know in your little ball
and then you don't think about things
that are already too far so it seems
like there is still kind of some
distance to the closest real object yeah
yeah so uh
um all of this is is not to say that the
that uh the real objects are irrelevant
right like I agree that eggplants are
much more plausible issues than than ice
cream
um uh and that has to do with the kind
of real physical properties of of those
substances
um my point is is just that the physical
thing is not the defining thing right
it's not something in the object you
look to to decide whether it's a shoe or
not right it's it's something more
abstract about how it's used or made or
something like that
actually talk a a bit in this paper
about
um uh the concept of a postage stamp
right uh which is just an example of of
you know one that that people probably
have some some intuitions about where
um you you could easily think of posted
stamps which are fundamentally different
than any ones you've seen before right
you could think of one made of glass for
example you could think of one that was
an RFID tag
um there's probably physical
incarnations uh postage stamps like that
that everybody would agree uh should be
called a postage stamp
um and if if you try to get people to
Define it right you might say something
like well the postage stamp is something
you pay for and you put on a letter so
that the letter will be delivered by the
government or something like that right
so uh what this what the term means
right is is intrinsically connected to a
bunch of these other terms like payments
and and letters and being delivered and
those things
um and in fact if those terms change
meaning right so if uh for example
people develop a new way of paying for
things uh paying on the blockchain or
something right then you can to know
automatically that a postage stamp can
be paid for in in that way at least in
principle right so uh it's not just that
the the word is associated with those
other things but that its meaning is is
inherently connected to to those other
things
so uh that's that's one uh kind of take
on uh on why uh why reference to stuff
out in the world right is is not a good
way of of thinking about meaning
um let me tell you what one alternative
is
um actually but before I do that let me
just um show a couple of other
Alternatives which I think are also not
plausible but might be might be familiar
to people okay so what I just talked
about is this kind of world mapping view
right that there's some word and its
meaning is some physical object or or
something
um can think about other kinds of views
of Concepts and meaning
um
um might have a kind of feature Spacey
kind of use for Vector machines or
something right there's some abstract
feature space and a concept is some
dividing line or some region or
something in in this space
um uh that I I think is is uh maybe find
in in some narrow applications but what
I'll talk about next are are cases of of
uh say human cognition which really
don't fit well in into that picture in
the sense that things are much more
complicated for how people think about
Concepts and uh and their relationships
people might also have have this sort of
hierarchy or network view right so
sometimes people think oh sorry you
can't see this there's supposed to be
lines connecting one concept book in the
middle to a bunch of other Concepts
right and
um you might you know there's old
theories of say semantic organization or
very old old AI uh kind of approaches
right that
um uh think about building hierarchies
of of Concepts
um uh or sometimes you know networks of
of Concepts and trying to Define meaning
in terms of those relationships I
actually think that that both this and
and the feature and the world mapping
view
um have some of the some kind of uh
useful Properties or useful insights
about Concepts but just aren't quite the
whole thing offer reasons that I'll talk
about uh next so
um let me just start with uh start
trying to introduce this kind of other
view of Concepts
um uh by trying to to get people's
intuitions on a recent news story okay
so here's a little recent news from the
US versus Trump uh I think this is not
the most recent indictment but one or
two indictments ago
um uh if you look through it you you can
uh read all about
um uh Pence and Trump and and efforts to
to manipulate the election and things
um here's a little paraphrase of one of
the paragraphs in IDC so Pence the vice
president right opposed A Trump team
lawsuit arguing that the vice president
could reject electoral votes so Pence
didn't want want them to argue that he
could reject electoral votes
he said to Trump that he didn't have
constitutional Authority and that the
action would be improper this is
according to Pence's uh notes at the
time and Trump responded you're too
honest
okay according to Pence's notes so think
about that situation and everything you
you know about this context right and uh
think about an answer to a question like
why did Trump say this
right
if you think about that uh
um probably what's going on as you think
about it right is you're thinking about
uh lots of other things and how they're
related to this situation like what
Trump was trying to achieve maybe what
kind of personality Trump had uh what
you know Trump was trying to do defense
is he trying to manipulate him into into
taking some kinds of actions what
exactly that that action would have
right in terms of of the election
um everybody is perfectly capable of
reasoning through these and coming up
with uh you know kind of plausible
causal story about what's happening
right it feels like we can come up with
our own kind of internal explanations
about uh events like these
um and in fact that process of coming up
with internal explanations interrelated
uh kind of Concepts and and meanings
um is one that that people in
developmental psychology have been very
interested in and excited about as a as
a theory of uh kind of human cognition
so
um uh basic observation is that people
form these uh very richly interconnected
systems of Concepts right all of the
kind of interconnected stuff you you
would need to draw on in order to answer
a question like that which feels totally
totally normal
um people sometimes call these intuitive
theories right you have some intuitive
theory of how Trump is acting or how the
political system would work or uh um
some intuitive theory of what you know
Pence might be doing or might be be
trying to achieve and these things are
often compared to theories in science
right so
um um uh you can think of the you can
think of your theory of why Trump might
do this is kind of analogous to a little
scientific theory right it has some
pieces it has some relationships between
the pieces it has some Dynamics
um and maybe you can uh look at all of
that and and kind of Reason about it
causally as you might reason about any
other kind of system that that you've
you've encountered
um so the idea that that uh people and
maybe most notably kids do this uh is
one which is is really he uh had been
very popular in in cognitive development
um um Champion baby most most
prominently by Allison gothnic who's a
developmental psychologist uh here at
Berkeley
um let me just give you a quick example
of of how kids uh how how experiments
with with kids like uh kids uh sometimes
go in in this domain so uh here's a um
an experiment from lazota and and Gelman
uh so kids are showing these two foxes
right which you might notice are
identical pictures okay
um and then they're told things uh about
these foxes and asked what what they
could do in order to to answer a
question right so this is like a simple
version of why did Trump say that
um you might be told that one is an
animal and one is a toy
what could you do in order to determine
which one is an animal and and which one
is a toy right
um
in this experiment uh kids will say that
you should do things like check the
insides right like check their guts or
whatever right open them up and and see
uh or uh look at their behavior right
um if it acts like an animal then then
you could use that to figure out which
one which one is the animal which one's
the toy or look at their parents right
like uh you know the the animal will
have will have animal parents and the
toy won't right
um and importantly they don't just say
yeah you can check everything about
these they know for example that age is
not relevant right so they they won't
tell you that uh that age would tell you
which one is an animal and which
it's worth pausing and just thinking
about this and and what this means in
terms of conceptual representations
right uh because you can think about
your concept of what makes something an
animal or or what makes something a toy
and kind of like the postage stamp
example right it's intrinsically
connected to these other things like
what parents are or what's going on with
your guts inside right or what your
behavior is right that concept is just
intrinsically linked there and kids I
think these are preschoolers
um uh uh know that from a a pretty young
age
is a dog one is a wolf what would you do
okay
um kids basically say the same things
there you could check the insides you
could look at Behavior you could look at
their parents to see if they had a a dog
parent or or a wolf parent
um some of these are actually kind of
interesting right because I don't think
anybody knows uh at least I don't what
what you would look for on the insides
to distinguish a dog versus a wolf right
like
um uh maybe you could go down to DNA or
I'm sure you could go down to DNA to
tell that
um but people have the intuition that
like okay there's something about being
in this category which depends on these
other these other aspects of of being in
the concept yeah
I read this much simpler it's like
you look like both of these are visual
things it's just that you're trying to
project it into the language but
actually what the kids are probably
meaning is you know you will you will
know it when you see it and when you you
know play with it right it's a vision
and interaction
yeah yeah I mean at age is neither
yeah yeah so I I think it's true that
that uh yes all all of these are are
visual cues I don't know of experiments
that look at non-visual cues
um uh but I agree yeah that's that's
interesting I'll give you one one other
example though where they they don't
where they they know that there's no cue
right so if you tell them that one is
named Amanda and one is named Melissa uh
then they'll reject all of these as
tests right they'll say okay the insides
are not going to tell you which one is
Amanda
um the behavior and the parents and the
age and these things are not going to
okay so all of this is just to say that
um people have a a uh even kids right
have have pretty sophisticated theories
of how Concepts relate to other Concepts
right
um and in fact in a situation like this
right there's nothing visual apparently
that that could tell you right so it's
not a visual discrimination task it's
really a kind of conceptual one
um that's asking you to to to look at
other kinds of conceptual features and
things
um so uh people have these intuitive
theories
um then one kind of proposal
um quite a few people have argued for is
that meeting arises from essentially the
role that a word or a symbol or a
concept plays in this Theory right like
like the the meaning of animal is really
just intrinsically related to these ways
of testing it and these kinds of
features and uh all of the other things
that are not kind of simple semantic
Associates with animal but
um are uh kind of deeply connected in in
in in the sense of an intuitive Theory
um I was trying to come up with examples
where uh
um uh this you know will give people
this this intuition right that
um uh you know if you try to Define
these words if you try to Define what an
indictment is for example it's very hard
to do it in a way that doesn't reference
other legal terms another kind of social
constructs and and uh uh and Concepts
that that you already have right it's
kind of intrinsically related to the
system of other Concepts in terms right
chord change is kind of like this too in
music right you have to talk about
chords and notes and and
um uh circle of fifths or whatever right
like these things are just intrinsically
related I think force and physics is is
like this
um it's very hard to talk about it in in
isolation independent of
um you know experiments or other
Concepts or things or if I said like
what does a bobbin do in a sewing
machine okay right like you have to talk
about thread and you have to talk about
the processes of Sony just the meaning
of these things are just all
intrinsically linked together
so
um this uh idea that meaning it's not
about reference it's about the role that
something plays is called conceptual
role Theory
um meaning of a word or concept is
determined by the the role that it plays
um and
um uh this uh has been argued for
um I think maybe most prominently by Ned
block who's a philosopher of mind uh who
wrote one of my my favorite paper titles
uh advertisement for a semantics of
psychology uh which is basically all
about you know how psychology needs a
theory of meaning and a theory of of
semantics and this idea of conceptual
role is is something that that could do
that so it can explain kind of where
meaning comes from it can uh um address
questions of how meaning depends on
things like your representations or
categories that you know
um can play nicely with compositionality
or other other aspects of language
um and I think maybe most most
compellingly can explain how you could
find meaning in brains right so if you
open up a brain and you start recording
from from neurons uh you know it's
really unclear what it means for there
to be reference in there reference to
the external World in there
um but maybe you could kind of make
sense of of patterns of activity in a
way that
um uh lets you uh kind of interpret
systems of signals and and and
representations
um uh let me give you and just one one
other example of this that maybe might
might make things uh more clear
um this idea of conceptual role
semantics I think is is also how meaning
Works in uh say a computer okay also I
think in in mathematics which is why I
was deferring the the questions about
about mathematics but you could look at
something like this right this is a
floating Point uh representation and ask
what makes the bits in this
representation mean what they do right
in particular what makes the first bit
mean the sign bit right it's nothing
about being the first one because there
have been dozens of different
conventions for floating Point numbers
which put the sign bid in in all kinds
of different places right uh what makes
it mean that sign bit is how it
interacts with all of the other
operations that you can do with floating
Point numbers right so meaning and
sometimes comes from the interaction
between symbols or in other words their
conceptual role so in particular like
what does negation do right if I have a
negation operator okay it flips the sign
bit great okay that's that's uh that's
that's where it gets its meaning from
right or what does addition do does
addition do the right thing with respect
to the sign bit uh or multiplication or
rounding uh or whatever right so what
makes this the the floating Point
representation of what makes that uh
first bit represent sine is nothing
intrinsic in the representation itself
it's how it interacts with all of the
other components of the of the system
approach where there's Concepts in there
sort of
um
yeah so
um in a uh like I I think that um like
there's certainly Concepts people have
that are hierarchical right so we know
that dogs are a kind of animal and
animals are kind of a living thing
um I think what what that kind of
picture is missing is that our
representations are actually you know
like computational objects like they do
something right they interact with each
other
um and they allow us to solve you know
certain kinds of inference problems and
and you know all of the stuff you could
do with your Concepts like the the Trump
example right
um yeah so the claim is not that they're
not hierarchical right it's that the the
interesting important things they do uh
come from interactions kind of
internally between Concepts much like
the the way that the sign bit is
interesting or important here uh comes
from its interactions with things like
negation and multiplication
what do you think here is perfect
what I have trouble with
buying this as an exclusive theory of
semantics yep just like
you gave good arguments against the that
meaning is just reference okay I think
you demolish that theory but now you put
up another theory which also I find that
it has some good aspects but to create
make that an exclusive theory is
problematic so if we look at children
growing up there are these studies or
sort of concreteness judgments so the
vocabulary of a child at two there are a
lot of words in there like milk and
bottle and jump and sit and so forth
which are very concrete Concrete in a
visual sense Concrete in a motor program
sense yeah yeah at the age of 10 they
have words but like justice and fairness
and so forth which are very much which
fit much better into this conceptual
role story whereas the vocabulary of a
child at two maybe one where this kind
of groundedness to sensory motor
experience is a much better account yeah
yeah and this is it's not problematic
for me why do we need to have one
exclusive theory for meaning yeah these
are aspects of uh of meaning yeah yeah I
I agree so I I think that
um uh you can think of the physical
reference right as in some sense one of
the conceptual roles that something can
have right it like
um it is important I'm not sure we know
kind of how abstract kids early meanings
are uh for for those kinds of words
right because it's not it has to be a
little bit abstract because you'll call
a new bottle that you see a bottle still
right so you have some abstraction away
from the examples of bottles that that
you've seen but I agree it feels uh
early on very concrete and and uh much
less abstract than Things become later
so yeah
yeah
make sure I understand
saying so and so is um is their
character to think of this that you're
saying that meaning is basically like
some homomorphism onto some either
intuitive or formal Theory
uh sure
so then maybe the follow-up question is
like which how do we know which
homomorphisms are valid because I could
always uh if I can have some arbitrary
correspondence mapping I could make
anything correspond to anything else
know what's allowed here yeah so um I
don't think anybody has been that formal
people like uh Putnam have made this
kind of argument about understanding
computation and physical systems
basically saying like physical systems
like a brain or in his example a wall
right are are uh so complicated that I
could come up with kind of any mapping
back and forth between the states of it
and the states of a kind of arbitrary
computational system
um and um that's probably a much longer
thing to get into I'll just say that I
don't think I have a very easy answer
about that right um uh I think of this
as as not kind of uh uh certainly not
formalized in in that sense but in in
sort of a higher level in terms of like
what kinds of theories we should be
looking for right um and then there's
lots of work to do in in in terms of
making that precise uh so yeah yeah
Klein actually uses that example to
motivate this kind of theory in like
1950s philosophy
sorry which example Klein uses this
example uses an example of Gaba guy you
see something popping out and you're
like how do you know Gava guy means
rabbit and not running and not whole and
something else because the real world
doesn't determine what uh what a meaning
is yeah
have been extensively determinated
operationalized Authority can you
comment on that
um I don't think so yeah so I I mean
I'll I can talk uh
um I have a couple examples of uh kind
of learning intuitive theories
um
um which you know essentially have this
this kind of character so of
um uh taking data and then trying to
come up with some structures that obey
the the right relations right and
um uh yeah I'll talk a little bit about
that but there hasn't been a ton of work
on so
yeah
um could you talk about how this Theory
deals with when the same symbols or
words are in different kind of theories
or settings like is it does it kind of
mean that the symbols themselves don't
have meaning or how are the kind of the
meaning shared across different contexts
yeah so
um uh that's a an interesting question
um that I think people have have not
resolved very well so
um uh you know your symbol for your
father might play a bunch of different
roles right because you know you know
what job your father has and you know
what family relations you know
um what hobbies and and
um uh I don't think that there's there's
good kind of formalized accounts of of
how to make sense of all of that
um so there's there's not great theories
of kind of formalizing conceptual roles
um
um I'll give some arguments why I think
it's possible that language models are
doing this at least in a in a tiny
version
um but in terms of like rich and kind of
human-like uh conceptual roles I think
that's one of the the key problems
that's hard to solve so
is there another one yeah
in the substance of the ontology of
humorous minds and Bobby also subset of
all possible future invented uh uh
Concepts and so on
sorry what was what was the I missed the
very first part what was the question
part so the question is whether you
think
um
existing oncology
what you are using now
that of the ontology of humans mind that
we haven't haven't fully explored and
probably that is also a subset of what
kind of can be uh inventive or creative
uh produced Concept in the beginning by
ontology do you mean these these
theories uh I mean terms yeah Concepts
yeah yeah I mean uh uh I don't think any
of these is quite the right answer right
like these things are actually very
difficult to to figure out
um
um but I think they're kind of pointing
in in some useful directions or
something so uh I don't know if that
answers your question but
[Music]
um in terms of which symbols like uh
mental representations or yeah
yep so yeah so just just to make sure
that you
how far do you still have to like do you
have any uh I have a little ways to go
okay so maybe we should push this toward
the after after at the end because it
seems like a you know a deeper
discussion yeah yeah okay great
um
uh okay so
um I talked about this these kinds of
accounts of of meaning right
um on particular meaning as as
conceptual role
um and let me talk a little bit about
learning conceptual roles and and why we
might think that's uh plausible or or
useful
um uh seems to me at least that
um large language models almost
certainly need to learn some of these
pieces of conceptual role
um but these kind of things seem really
necessary for the stuff large language
models are good at right writing
coherent texts or doing translations or
providing definitions or providing
elaborations or explanations right all
of those things require you to put
symbols in the right relationships with
other symbols right and uh that means
that uh like to do those things well you
essentially have to have some little
components of conceptual roles right
um one way to think about this is that
human meanings or human conceptual roles
generated the text right so maybe a
smart inferential model right could
invert that and figure out what were the
likely conceptual roles that uh that
that generated the thing that I saw um I
like this this fragrant quote right the
structure of sentences serves as an
image of the structure of thoughts right
some projection of our of our thoughts
or our meanings our conceptual roles
that gets realized into into sentences
yeah
control
the the which examples are you going to
recapitulate with that in government's
Tupac examples
uh
no I wasn't going to go back to that but
I'll I'll talk about a a study in larger
models in a minute
uh uh okay
okay um a lot of people have the
intuition this is not possible I think
this is kind of the the vendor and
Marcus intuition that our thoughts
really get projected into this kind of
impoverished sequence of sounds right
how could you discover something like
Rich conceptual roles uh there right uh
if you just have this this projection of
of language how could that ever support
you know rich and interesting kinds of
of conceptual roles
um uh we one kind of way that I think is
a helpful analogy although not not kind
of a mathematically precise
implementation or something
um people may know these embedding
theorems from from dynamical systems
which I think are are very cool
um there's this paper called geometry
from a Time series
um uh which essentially shows that in
some cases you can take projections of
dynamical systems and recover things
which capture the the structure of the
Dynamics from that projection
um so in particular in this paper they
go through this which is the the Rossler
attractor uh this is a you know system
of of uh three-dimensional system of of
differential equations
and what you can do is take a
one-dimensional projection of those
Dynamics so you can look at just the X
location of of what's happening there
um and through a clever trick um uh
essentially translating the the one
Dimensions into three dimensions using
um by going uh backwards in time some
number of steps uh you can actually
recover the structure of this from the
one-dimensional projection
okay
um and uh there's other kind of General
theorems about when this is possible
tokens in embedding theorem and things
like that the the kind of Point here
right is is that uh we shouldn't really
have strong intuitions about what's
possible from some projection of of
thoughts right because oftentimes there
there's uh it might be possible for for
people to uh or for for learning models
to Recon to to reconstruct kind of
interesting parts of uh of the structure
of some system just from simple kind of
measurements of that system
um actually Shaw here the the senior
author wrote in uh an entire book on
recovering the the kind of dynamical
properties of a dripping water faucet
um uh where you can measure the the time
between drips and and figure out things
about the kind of latent variables and
latent structures they're using
techniques that are that are a lot like
these
um in Psychology actually people have
also been interested in in uh kind of
closely related types of models so
there's this work by uh Roger Shepard in
the in the 80s uh which essentially
would would take behavioral judgments
and try to infer the underlying
structures uh behind them so for example
this uh this Matrix here is uh different
colors so different wavelengths of light
and then confusability between them on
uh judgment tasks so just you know how
similar are these things or how
confusable is one color with another
um and he Shepard was was using
multi-dimensional scaling to to go from
data like this
um up to a representation like this
which you might recognize as a color
wheel right basically you can arrange uh
arrange points
um so that their distances correspond to
the the distances and the confusion
Matrix
um and therefore uh recover something
about the kind of underlying in this
case psychological structure uh that
that generated that data
um people have have also uh done similar
kinds of things in uh learning kind of
real formalized versions of uh uh of
theories or of intuitive theories I
really like this this paper uh by Tomer
Allman and Noah Goodman and and Josh
who's speaking speaking next on learning
a theory of magnetism so basically you
take observations of uh which objects
interact with which other with with
other objects uh and uh do some uh
learning to to to acquire a kind of high
level theory of you know the the fact
that there are you know two different
kinds of of magnetic objects
um and those two different kinds of
things will interact with each other but
they won't interact with things that are
that are non-magnetic right so this is
like a little tiny mini intuitive theory
that you can acquire just from from very
simple uh you might think kind of
impoverished data about about
interactions
okay so when people talk about llms just
being based on text
um I think that isn't really enough to
to conclude anything about what theories
they might deduce right or what kinds of
internal structures and and conceptual
roles they they might induce from that
text
um in fact there's some evidence I think
that uh um what they are inducing
um uh looks pretty plausible at least in
in kind of simple domains so
um there's this paper by uh Grandin and
colleagues
um which essentially looked at uh word
embedding vectors and projected them
onto uh say intuitive Dimensions so here
you have a bunch of words you project
them onto this line which is a line
connecting small and large okay so all
of our our high dimensional word vectors
get product projected onto the small
versus large line and we take that as a
way of measuring you know how large
versus small different different objects
are
um and then the question is you know is
in a model trained only on on text
prediction uh is that product it does
that projection uh recover anything
human-like about the underlying
conceptual spaces
um and they show yes it does so uh
here's six plots where the x-axis is is
the semantic projection right so how far
on that small the large line something
is and then the y-axis is human ratings
of how small versus large and an object
is right you can see that the
correlations here are not perfect but
they're also not garbage right they're
uh actually quite strong I think for for
a a model like this that things which
you know the model calls wet versus dry
or big versus small or dangerous versus
safe
um uh people also uh agree with right so
just in predicting text this thing has
recovered these kinds of aspects of
semantic structure
um latent in the in the word Vector
representations yeah but this this is
probably sitting there in Android
uh well it does have something to do
with the real world oh it's like a you
know it's a small you know a small and
large would just be linguistic
crosstructs and you're testing it on on
language oh I see you think it's it's
that you say small tiger versus large
tiger or something and you know and do
that puppy is always small tiger is
always large yeah so uh it might be true
in engrams I'm not sure I don't think
that they that they looked at that
um
um I don't think that that uh I don't
think that defeats the argument though
right because I I think it it is the
case that you know even engram
statistics are are statistics about word
relations right
um so it might be that you don't need
fancy language models or something to to
do this but yeah but you're not actually
like you don't need real world for this
to work
uh well the the the real world generated
how often you hear a small puppy versus
large puppy right so uh the the the the
real world is mirrored in those
statistics and then the the
configuration that system comes up with
is also one that mirrors those
properties of the real world
I think yeah
much closer to engrands than it is to
large language models and the properties
we're seeing are just so much wilder
than any of these inventing kind of
tricks
uh many practice Oh you mean the large
language is much smarter than this
I don't even see how this is comparable
terrible in a way right like this pops
out of like this PC
we're seeing like these
large language yeah yeah so I I mean I I
don't think this explains wild emergent
behaviors I think that this this was
just trying to say that uh you know when
you train on text prediction you
configure yourself to align with with
some of the true properties of the world
which are reflected in the text
statistics that's all yeah
okay since I'm short on time I'll skip
this I'll just say that there's um
there's other papers looking at uh
Transformers
um and uh kind of how they relate to
Classic studies on on Concepts in in
cognitive science past the kinds of
effects but I'll skip that
um uh maybe I'll go very briefly just
just through this this kind of fun
experiment this is uh Mark uh gorenstein
in my lab has been
um interested in in learning uh Concepts
just from from linguistic uh linguistic
experience maybe linguistic prediction
um he's been doing these these uh kind
of cool experiments where we give people
uh passages of natural language
where uh there's some blanks so here uh
here's a passage the myth of blank is so
powerful that the very words Contour
blank of strudel and blank in a cozy
peonies Cafe blah blah blah and uh the
job of of participants in this is to
learn where to put the word Dax okay so
Dax is a novel word they've never
encountered before
um uh you have to read this and and
understand the context and stuff in
order to uh to to figure that out and
see where Dax should go secretly behind
the scenes
um these uh this example has been chosen
as a um just from a big Corpus of text
of a really rare word that people
probably don't know okay so the rare
word here is soccer tort okay and that
means that that this uh language like
where soccer tour actually occurred here
um uh was generated from from real
people and presumably reflects the
underlying meaning and things of Sakura
tort okay
um I don't even know if I'm saying that
that correctly uh but with examples with
enough examples of these people will
learn where Dax is they get feedback on
whether or not they were correct
according to to whether they chose the
place where soccer tour actually
actually appeared okay so we're we're
having them do kind of a version of a
prediction task
um uh trying to to figure out where
where this word goes ah but they they
don't actually see the word they see it
as as Dax
um people get pretty decent at this so
up to 80 percent or or so uh depending
on the word
um uh these are just sorry these are the
examples of of The Words which generated
the the Unseen context
um and after that we asked them a bunch
of questions so we asked them some
reading comprehension we asked them
feature questions about Dax right is Dax
a man-made objects do biologists
typically study Dax do people use Dax in
painting uh just a whole collection of
kind of basic feature kind of concept e
questions we give them an image
recognition task right uh picking out
soccer tours the The Real Thing versus
uh versus Alternatives and we also ask
them for explicit definitions right
these contexts are not definitions
they're they're not saying here's what a
socrator is it's it's naturalistic
usages of the of the object
um and what we find actually is is
within
um
go back to uh within a about 20 trials
or so
um sorry everything is is after 20
trials uh people are actually very very
good at judging conceptual features for
these uh for these Concepts
um almost at ceiling in in most of the
the kinds of feature questions we we ask
them
um here's each uh uh each word on a row
and then features here on on the x-axis
um almost everything is red meaning
they're they're good at this they're
also good at
um at picking
um which picture is the object right so
they've never encountered any pictures
at all but but they're um they're 80 or
so good at picking these things out and
they're even good at giving definitions
for for these terms okay so here's a uh
dictionary or dictionary or something
definition of soccer tour that's a
chocolate cake or toward of Austrian
origin invented by France soccer
supposedly In 1832 for some prince in in
Vienna
um and people just from these contexts
20 of them will learn things like it's a
chocolate dessert similar to a cake that
was originally most commonly made in
Vienna I think it's a type of chocolate
cake that can be ordered for dessert in
Austria uh kind of rich chocolate cake
from from Vienna and so on okay so so
people are are uh
um pretty good at uh at uh taking kind
of in context language use and figuring
out underlying aspects of of conceptual
representation from that
but they will never be able to taste it
and it tastes so good
idea yeah I'd never heard of it okay so
let me just wrap up here so
um uh I think of of these kind of
conceptual roles uh or theories as
really both a strength and a weakness of
uh of at least current large language
models
um one is is that large language models
I think seem very good at learning kind
of shallow but but broad theories right
so things like could shoes be made out
of eggplants or what would happen if
shoes were made out of eggplants right
they would know uh you know what some
bad downsides of that kind of thing
might be right or
um uh answer you know basic kinds of
questions that might rely on
um uh you know kind of reasoning through
one or two kind of links about the the
relationships between the objects
involved in a situation like that
um I think it's been very surprising to
people that this works uh this works so
well right and and uh part of I think
what makes it surprising is is that
um uh you know these these uh models are
able to be trained on a huge number of
words right and so sort of superficially
knowing a little bit about conceptual
roles of a huge number of words seems to
to get you pretty far
um um in terms of seeming convincing in
in terms of language production
um but it's also these conceptual roles
and theories are also a weakness and
they don't seem very good at robust and
precise theories right so if you think
about conceptual roles like in
mathematics right how you define say a
natural number how you define an
integral or something right like all of
those are are uh symbolic kinds of
theories which are uh precise and which
support you know change of reasoning of
arbitrary length right and that's what
these these systems really seem not to
be uh not to be very good at likely
that's because there's some important
things which are missing right things
like uh grounding uh things like
reasoning or even richer richer kinds of
theories um I think Josh will will talk
about this this uh this sum next I think
that there's a a kind of broader view of
Concepts and meanings which is really I
think the most exciting for people that
work on on Concepts and and concept
representations in cognitive psychology
um which is that large language models
have really shown how vectors can do
things that were long thought to be
impossible for non-symbolic models right
in particular these kinds of arguments
from people like foder and pollution
about compositionality and systematicity
and productivity right all of these
kinds of things that people have pointed
to as as uh characteristic features of
of thinking and have argued with
characteristic features of of symbolic
thinking just turn out not to be right
right it turns out you can get you can
get vectors to to do those things
um and I would argue that the the
solution to why vectors could do those
things is probably that that uh what
these models are doing is training
vectors that encode conceptual roles
right like what they're learning is is
representations of meaning which capture
the important parts of of conceptual
roles this is actually something which
has been
um long sought after in say
computational Neuroscience there's
things like vector symbolic
architectures that are are very exciting
ways of encoding say arbitrary symbolic
systems or arbitrary mathematical
systems
um uh into vectors
um and I think that some marriage of of
those two things is is uh going to be
very exciting
um uh so large language models point to
a theory of meaning that's that's based
on uh essentially vector-based
conceptual roles right and perhaps can
capture a lot of the different features
of of meaning that uh um people in say
cognitive science or cognitive
development
um uh have tried to kind of bring out in
human conceptual systems right like that
our meanings are gradient or that they
have hierarchies that we know things
like definitions and we can make
inferences about relationships and
similarities and all of those things
seem um seem like things that you can
encode at least in principle in in
vectors
which is great
um so
um uh I'll skip that let me just end
there um oh thank you again for the
invitation and thanks also to all of my
my co-authors on uh that work here
thank you
all right yes
um maybe I'm reading too much into it
but but it seemed to me that you hinted
at um
what these Vector representations and
large language models tell us about both
human cognition as well as about
language the nature of language uh could
I ask you to do a projective measurement
and come out and say something about
that
um
that they tell us that that vectors are
are really plausible they kind of show
us how vectors are are plausible for
meanings right and
um the way in which I think that they're
plausible for meanings is that they
encode conceptual roles
um uh that's what I would say and I I
think until them until kind of recent
deep learning I think it was really
unclear right so people had argued for
decades about whether you know the
foundation of Concepts was definitions
or is it like somehow similarities or is
it that you just know a word and you
know a bunch of associated features or
or whatever right
um and I I think one of the
um the main insights for example is is
that uh you can extract a definition
from a large language model we've been
given it some of these kind of human
experiments we've done and they're
they're pretty good at coming up with
the chocolate toward kind of definitions
from those
um and that tells you that the
definitions can be encoded into into
vectors right and that's great right
that that that that that means that uh
you don't need to think about deaf
missions as the defining part of of
Concepts right there's some other kind
of more abstract
um you know High dimensional space or
whatever that that defines the meanings
and the sense in which it defines the
meanings is in terms of the
relationships between vectors on the
tasks that you use the concepts for
um yes natural since the brain encodes
information with lots of neurons yeah
firing firing brain this should not be
surprising so it's not surprising it's
um uh it was always unclear how that was
even possible
um
yeah exactly yeah yeah
it's like everybody always kind of knew
that there had to be a continuous system
which could support these things but
when you look at you know the
discreetness and language or this
discreetness in mathematics it was
always kind of unclear where that could
come from um so that's why I think
things like vector symbolic
architectures are very exciting too
so yeah when a human fills in the
meaning they're using a lot of context
that they've gotten from The Real World
yeah when an octopus tries to fill in
the meaning they have much less context
to work with yeah and when a llm fills
in the meaning they have no kind of
context for it but yeah I was wondering
if you had thoughts about the
differences and yeah it's it's really
interesting interesting to think of
what's exactly happening in that human
experiment because I agree it's transfer
of stuff you know like you've
encountered cakes and you've encountered
fancy pastries or or whatever and uh
um part of what you know about those
meanings are the grounded parts right
you know what a cake looks like which is
why you can you can recognize the the
pictures and and things
um I always have a little bit of trouble
thinking about it because it's not never
quite clear to me exactly what it means
to transfer something grounded like it
feels a little bit like in order for it
to transfer at all it has to be a little
bit abstract
um
um but I agree that that's that's the
right question to ask and we don't have
anything there's certainly no no
evidence about
um you know how exactly people solve
that problem or the way in which it
relies on conceptual roles versus
grounded experience or something okay so
we'll have one more question meanwhile
maybe we can have the next speakers
start setting up
um yeah thanks uh Steve for the great
talk um I wanted to understand better
what the argument was in this kind of uh
conceptual embedding experiment because
it seems like you could just ask the llm
what whether it's tall or not like you
didn't really need to do this projection
to know that it can do this task so is
it somehow is there something special
about the fact that you're looking at
embeddings rather than the outputs or
what's kind of going on there
um that's a good question so I I think
you probably could do that I I don't
know how I don't know how the results
would compare
um if you just asked versus not
um
yeah I'm not sure
um I mean I I think it's
like if it doesn't succeed on just
asking then it's interesting to know
whether it's it's kind of latent
representation still has that
information or not so
um uh but I I I don't know the the whole
Space of kind of how you how you can
interrogate these these models for those
questions so
let's
uh
[Applause]
um we will have plenty of time to to
talk to him more at um at the uh
Refreshments after this talk and who
knows maybe there will be zachar torters
there uh which is by the way amazing if
you're in Vienna you should absolutely
try it
um so unfortunately the next speaker
could not be here Josh Tenenbaum is is
um is a is a latent variable in this
session because both Stephen was a a
student of of Josh's and